claude blanche raison de bonjour aux
jours heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
avec nord stream 2 quels changements
dans les relations finalement entre la
russie la france et l'allemagne
je crois que 7,7 inaugurer cette fin des
travaux de north m2 est une bonne
nouvelle moi je vais d'abord souligner
que c'est la prolongation de rapports
traditionnels entre
la russie d'un côté la france et
l'allemagne de löw dans le domaine du
gaz à l'époque soviétique gaz de france
avait des contrats à long terme avec
gazprom et ses contrats en fonctionner
avec une très grande régularité même
chose pour orgas avec gazprom et ces
contrats ont donné toute satisfaction
pour la régularité des
approvisionnements alors aujourd'hui
technologies plus modernes des gazoducs
eux sous marin qui vont
approvisionner donc le marché allemand
et le marché européen en général c'est
donc une bonne nouvelle et c'est la
continuation d'une coopération dans le
domaine du gaz qui est très importante
depuis déjà longtemps ça intervient à un
moment où madame merkel qui était
beaucoup à ce projet va quitter la
chancellerie allemande puisque les
élections allemandes sont prévues le 26
septembre et que les madame merkel se
retire de toutes manières et les
sondages indiquent qu'il ya une
incertitude sur la succession
son successeur à la cd ou sur l'athlète
ne fait pas de très bons très bons
scores par contre lorsqu'on interroge
les allemands les scores de monsieur la
chose qui est actuellement ministre des
finances mais qui est des parties spd
fait un des scores assez assez bon il
est donc possible que monsieur lé
chercheur de vienne le chancelier
allemand d'ici la fin de l'année mais il
faut avant cela que peut lier cette
élection et qui est coalition
gouvernementale qui semble puisque aucun
parti ne peut avoir la majorité
au parlement au parlement donc il faudra
sans doute une coalition si c'est
monsieur choc ce sera probablement une
coalition avec les verts si c'était
monsieur match est ce serait peut-être
la reconduction de la coalition actuelle
mais tout ceci reste voir joly dit parce
que les verts avaient exprimé leur
désaccord avec nord stream 2 je pense
qu'ils seront réalistes et que surtout
si c'est la seule chose qui est le
chancelier et bien effectivement
considérons que cette infrastructure
existe et que dans le fond c'est une
bonne chose pour l'approvisionnement en
gaz du marché allemand et européen pour
ce qui est de l'objection monsieur
politique à savoir le fait qu'il
pourrait avoir un jour un manque à
gagner en droit de transit pour eux pour
l'ukraine et bien l'accord qui a été
passé entre monsieur joe weise les
manades merkel fait que après 2024 après
le contrat qui règle la question des
droits de transit avec l'ukraine entre
l'ukraine et la russie eh bien il faudra
probablement renouveler ce contrat est
assuré que les crêtes touchera toujours
les mêmes droits de transit ne sera pas
pénalisée donc toute cette conclusion
elle est positive et pour la france
aussi encore une fois c'est la
continuation d'une tradition de
coopération gazière entre nos trois pays
cela veut dire que les relations
s'améliorent entre la russie d'une part
la france et l'allemagne d'autre part
même si au dernier conseil européen la
proposition franco-allemande de tenir un
sommet entre l'union européenne et la
russie n'a pas été acceptée par les
partenaires du nord de l'europe de l'est
de l'europe mais puisque la france prend
la présidence de l'union européenne et
le 1er janvier prochain il est possible
on rediscutera il est probable qu on
rediscutera de ce sujet parce
qu'effectivement un sujet qui était et
qui est toujours source de tension
comment l'expliquer
par l'histoire je crois qu'il faut quand
même comprendre les polonais les baltes
qui ont une histoire compliquée les
baltes ont été victimes du pacte molotov
robben robin preuve les pays baltes ont
été annexés successivement par les
allemands puis par les soviétiques et
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
respecter
ce ressentiment historique
l'apologue la même façon mais il faut le
traiter et pour cela il faut je crois
nommer les choses et réduire les
tensions réduire les tensions notamment
entre ces pays et la russie pourquoi que
l'allemagne s'y est beaucoup employé la
france aussi il va il faut continuer et
en effet probablement réunir un sommet
assez rapidement entre la russie et
l'union européenne
de la même manière que joe biden a
dialogué avec le président de la lumière
poutine le 16 juillet dernier à genève
avec
3,3 à trois formes de sujets les sujets
sur lesquels on a un intérêt commun
évident pour les américains et les
russes c'est naturellement la stabilité
stratégique dans le domaine nucléaire
des sujets sur lesquels on a des lignes
rouges si tu m'attaques je me défendrai
et puis des sujets sur lesquels on peut
coopérer avec notamment l'envoi
immédiatement après de john kerry à
moscou reçu en grande pompe par le
président poutine ne parte pour parler
du réchauffement climatique et de la
préparation de la coop 26 eh bien il
faut simplement sans qu'elles limitent
toujours les états unis dit que l'union
européenne adopte la même démarche le
plan de la méthode eh bien merci côte
blanche maison pour ce nouvel éclairage
un édito à revoir sur nos réseaux
sociaux